a writer for the atlantic explaining why
she's not interested in covering hunter
biden
my problem with hunter biden's laptop is
i think totally irrelevant i mean it's
not whether it's disinformation or i
mean i don't think the
hunter biden's
business relationships have anything to
do with who should be president of the
united states so
i i didn't find i don't find it to be
interesting i mean that that would be my
problem with th that as a as a major
news story
what was in her hand i don't know like
an orb it was an orb all right but the
hunter headache continues a new report
says the president's brother james biden
and hunter had over 150 transactions
involving global business affairs that
were allegedly flagged as concerning by
u.s banks including large wire transfers
you know dana
ann applebaum is her name yes uh i don't
blame her for dismissing a scandal
because she's she was instrumental in i
mean just by being in the media and not
even covering it so she can't act now
she can't do it i think look i i
understand like if you're not interested
in it okay that's fine right yeah no
problem but don't complain that others
are yeah and if the new york post is
interested in a story they should not be
kicked off of something just because
kicked off something meaning twitter
and and being ostracized basically for
six months when that now all the media
is coming back saying oh actually the
new york post was right yeah that's
absolutely not fair and we all know
they don't like this game but i'll play
it for a second if president trump had
written a letter for somebody in eric
trump's orbit that's all the media would
be talking about they would find great
interest in that so i'm fine you can be
interested in whatever you want but
don't complain about what other people
are interested in yeah and it what judge
you're smiling i don't know what you're
thinking about but it's something i want
to know
look at that you know what what kills me
about all of this is that
she doesn't apparently care about the
fundamental issue here and that is that
the president of the united states lied
to the american people in order to get
elected i know nothing of my son's
businesses i've never discussed my son's
businesses with him that laptop proves
that that is a lie and forget about you
know what the letter the the the letter
of recommendation i mean okay i'll say
i'll be really fair and and and and on
balance to me right now and say i don't
care about the la i'll tell you what i
care about i care about a guy going to
ukraine where there's incredible
corruption and going there on air force
two and saying if you don't fire the
prosecutor who's looking at the company
that my son gets a fortune from i'm
going to withhold 600 million dollars
from this corrupt country how dare you
use taxpayer money to influence a
foreign country in order to make your
son money so he can then pay your bills
we're talking farah we're talking all
kinds of uh tax evasion fraud money
laundering forget about the drugs and
the other stuff we're talking some
fundamental problems here with ukraine
russia and china being on the front
burner and this guy getting money from
all those countries you know in the
green room jessica you said i can't
believe president biden has not resigned
yet over this and it disgusted you how
uh the media and the democrats are
dismissing the scandal and i want to say
i agreed with you and i found your
opinion refreshing
i thought that was a private
conversation
[Laughter]
so a couple things i think are relevant
here and people tend to forget them so
two of the biggest scandals that plagued
hillary clinton and arguably one that
lost to the race in 2016 the email
scandal and then also uranium one were
owned and operated by the new york times
liberals favorite newspapers they were
the ones that broke the story they were
the ones that put it on the front page
every damn day
so when people say that the liberal
media just protects their own there is
no one that's more our own than hillary
clinton and she got taken down by the
liberal mainstream media second of all
to your point about the prosecutor
getting fired joe biden was the one who
went and he went on tax paradigm because
he was vice president united states of
america but the entire western
hemisphere supported that decision all
of the heads of western states and the
imf all agreed that that prosecutor had
to go and actually his actions hurt
hunter biden's business interests in
that country at the time
and i don't see any other way to read it
if you're being honest about it and i'm
not saying
it how did it hurt him he kept making
money what do you think put him in a
compromising position with barista he
had a job listen if you want to talk
about the fact that there are kids out
there that are benefiting off their
parents names will you go on forever
that happens in the private sector in
the public sector if you want to do it
we can talk about it
we're talking no it's jessie waters
junior taxpayer yes he uses it to get
into daycare yes he does he keeps saying
you know who i am
he's gonna need all the help he can get
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else